تخيلوا تخيلوا ان يصلح العطار ما يفسد
الدهر ويحملنا من اقصى العمر الى الشباب
مجددا تخيلوا ان يمر الزمن دون ان يؤثر
على مفاصينا او ذاكرتنا ومثل الكبر قد
يحدث هذا اسرع مما نتوقع فالعلماء على وشك
فك طلاسم الشيخوخه واعطائنا فرصه ان نعيش
باجساد فتيه وان كنا مسنين
هذا الامل ينبثق مع برنامج المعهد الوطني
الامريكي للصحه سله الحادث لرسم خرائط
خلايا الشيخوخه في الانسجه البشريه وتطوير
عقاقير لازالتها من الجسم
وخلايا الشيخوخه هي خلايا جذعيه اوهانها
الزمن فتوقفت عن الانقسام بشكل دائم وهي
بذلك خلايا لا حيه ولا ميته تنبعث منها
مواد كيميائيه تفسد الخلايا السليمه مما
اكسبها لقب الخلايا الزومبي
[موسيقى]
هناك ثلاثه ادويه مرشحه لمكافحه الشيخوخه
يتوقع الباحثون انها ستستخدم مثل المضادات
الحيويه اقربها في الحصول على موافقه
اداره الغذاء والدواء الامريكيه هو يو بي
اكس
والثاني خليط من دواء لعلاج سرطان الدم
وماده صبغيه توجد في اطعمه مثل العنب
وقد ادى هذا المزيج الى تحسن كبير في مرض
التلاف الرئوي اما المرشح الاخير فهو مركب
يحدث بشكل طبيعي يسمى
موجود في الفواكه والخضروات والشاي وهذا
المركب هو الافضل لازاله خلايا الشيخوخه
وتقليل الامراض المرتبطه بالعمر
[موسيقى]
والى حين نحصل على عقاقير سحريه يمكن
تخفيض علامات الشيخوخه بحسب المعهد
الامريكي الوطني للصحه عبر برنامج تمارين
منتظم لمده ثلاثه اشهر كما تشير الادله
الى ان النظام الغذائي والصيام المتقطع هو
الاليه الاكثر فاعليه لتطهير الخلايا
والحفاظ عليها لصباح العربيه هند ابراهيم
واشنطن